this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby
it'll work up there that's a strong
laser look at that bro well you know
it's a felony if you do that to
airplanes like people are doing
airplanes to the pilots except all the
stuff you'll be a real loser yeah
you're 54. it's a felony
you know it's a felony put the laser
down you don't even know if that's true
it probably is true but you know what I
don't know
I know some guys I know some guy got
arrested though I I I I know that too
and somehow it shouldn't bring something
like I don't so just so the audience
those chin brought lasers sometimes
we're doing current events like no Chin
that one so Jim uh brought us lasers
we're super immature so we've been
[__] with these lasers hey is it a
felony to use the laser at an airport
pretty sure it is like because people
sit on the outside you know by that in
and out and hit the pilots in the eyes
yeah probably or on airplanes
uh code sex however knowingly
intentionally aims the beam of a laser
pointer project it's actually a
misdemeanor okay but I know is that
legal I said illegal right I said felony
yeah he said that's all this this is Bro
Science dude that's what I was like yeah
it tracks though yeah and I kind of I
went along with it and I didn't we have
to
because nobody because you know are we
recording but this one yeah now we are
but this one says right here hey
pointing laser an aircraft is a federal
crime dude from the Federal Aviation
Administration but it's still a felony
so [__] off but um if it's a real laser
now I wanted just a couple things one
Brennan and I Eddie Bravo Sam tripley
Jeff dye are going to be doing stand up
at Venice West tomorrow Venice West in
Venice
um and uh I'll send out a flyer check
our our socials for that plus I'm
wearing
general purpose shoes yep from suplex so
I'm sorry I'm sorry about my crazy fresh
kicks did you pick these out yeah yeah
both of them I like them yeah you knew
what I'd like because they're simple
they're simple and they're these are
appropriate they're like Tom sacks is an
older guy so he makes the shoes yeah so
these are very comfortable oh those are
great and these are probably expensive
they're not giving these away no they're
not giving away bring up how much these
are they're great they're Tom sacks
Thompson
shoe Nike now Tom sack's got a little
bit of trouble I'm not gonna lie to you
there they are right there yeah I don't
want the price I like them a lot and I
love them I use the laser pointer here
so your shoe is here that's expensive
Jay has those oh man
I clicked on it oh there's your shoe
there not so much here
about time you had some cool sneakers
man that you're gonna wear for a week
mine are the most expensive and the best
ones
300. I'm one of those guys if you tell
me something's really expensive I'm like
I'll take them he had a pair of sneakers
there at suplex for 150 000.
[Music]
they were given to Eminem after he cut
his first album they were like oh the
Jordan one yeah yeah there's only like
yeah friends and family Eminem Jordan I
think five or fours but these brown ones
can be cool for you too those brown ones
that's right up your alley dude maybe
that's that Grandpa Brown Grandpa Brown
bro those are cool though huh that could
be you dude I like the yellow Jay has
the yellow he wore them this weekend
dude I can I could I was in La Jolla I
could move to La Jolla I know we always
get crunk on the cities we come from
I've been there so many places to argue
with in it I mean you're paying the same
taxes but that might be the move
everyone's uh you know Austin Nashville
why because it's the best weather of all
time and it's chill it's not too crowded
no the homeless is whatever it's amazing
it's amazing it's amazing yeah it's
amazing went to the Padres game on
Sunday that was the best thing about
doing Sunday's show you're not flying
out yeah you're you're two hours away
from LA but who cares about La yeah do
you care that much would you actually
think about moving down there I'd be
down yeah but yeah if we can move
everything down there yeah
it's great
I could do that
I would I would hologram in
yeah we'd have to figure it out huh
I wonder if we could do a hologram
situation it'd be kind of cool that
would suck that's when you know the
show's over let me go start holograming
it in
I mean the show's just over Dude
that's Zac Efron he's great
that kid's great the apology game is so
much fun
it's great Forte
Brad Forte he's funny super funny
yeah I could definitely live out there
[Music]
oh Santa Barbara
that's another place
to sell two too slow no stand up there
like in in San Diego you do The Comedy
Store in La Jolla yeah you got the ice
house I'm sorry you got Laugh Factory
and then you have uh American Comedy
Club yeah that other one and off the
hook no uh no no no
um
oh my God actually I know what you're
talking about drop the mic yes it's
great yeah close off the hook right
right yeah so yeah so you can you start
a whole circle of Comedy you had
Sparkles theater down there's a bunch
you can do down wow you really could
there's a whole comedy scene there
really is a big great comedy scene then
also you know big fight scene for me to
do on the shows damn dude it'd make more
sense than
Austin or Florida
yeah if we're gonna move but then yeah
then you'd have to move too dude if
we're gonna continue you can't hologram
it in no
one day a week
I go there you come here
oh yeah that would be you could pull it
off huh
yeah
probably by the way uh today is the
900th show
900. I'm the kid and Georgie made a
little something for you guys and all we
have to show for it are these laser
pointers let's see
oh wait wait sorry my bad
you started late I know dude 100
.
it's a long journey sure has buddy we're
about 200 episodes deep my man it seems
like just yesterday we were this
narration by the way Santa Monica in
your basement with a zoom mic and uh I
remember that and hearts full of joy and
we're just trying to make each other
laugh really young dumb fully remember
that like it was yesterday's it's crazy
to look back where we came from you know
I remember reaching down and saying to
myself Brennan mine always seems a
little bit hard sometimes you know what
I mean in other words I got all these
hormones pumping through my body and I
don't know what to do with all this
energy and you said right
put it into the podcast I sure did
something like that
yourself you said look at this guy oh
man
I don't remember this
just a quick little video I got great
quick
um the years of us aging like presidents
there was an acceleration of the age
it's been a hot second though different
Studios yeah nine hundo but there's you
must have done more yeah oh yeah
probably in the thousands oh we're in a
whale of a thousand yeah it's incredible
I know right
ten thousand hours wow
it's actually ten easily 10 000 hours oh
yeah all the podcasts we're doing
[__] nuts and really not missing any
time I mean a week a year than you but
yeah sure not really I know we've
already figured out the only the only
time it ever got uh dicey and we knew it
was coming is when you were doing the
Goldbergs and the the TV shows remember
because you were trying you'd had to
rush from set to there and then
sometimes it's out of your control the
set would like do we need another two
hours you'd call them in but all right I
guess I'll do it with Sasso or whatever
yeah I remember that sasso's used to
fill in all the time yeah not easy not
easy you'll come in with your shorts too
bro
yeah tiny shorts that was pretty cool
yeah that was fun it was a good time
look at this now still doing it still
doing it still the one Shania Twain
still the one makes me laugh still is
that Shania Twain no still the one
amazing left
um I uh want to be a singer but that's
not gonna happen anymore no dude you're
young
wait
you're still the one and then there's
still the one that's more of an upbeat
fun song yeah either way we get kicked
off yeah ain't that a [__] ain't that a
[__] let's take a little break because
UFC 289 is here this Saturday there will
be a live Cowboys fight command 7 P.M
Pacific I'm thick boy the Schmo Pauly
Shore Brian Callan and myself watching
UFC 289 go down it's sure to pack a
punch download the draftking Sportsbook
app right now use code fighter new
customers can make a five dollar UFC 289
bet and score 200 in bonus bets
instantly that's code fighter only at
draftking Sportsbook
you got a lot to bet on Irene's the big
dog on there I like douche as the
favorite as well so you can parlay them
but really you can make most your money
if you bet against Amanda Nunes she's
the biggest favorite there
uh gambling problem I thought you were
gonna read that call one Aaron Gambler
in Massachusetts call 800-327 50 50 or
visit gambling helpline line M a DOT org
in New York call 8778 Hope NY or text
Hope and why 467 369 in Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort Kansas in West
Virginia gambling problem call 1-800
Gambler or visit www.1800 gambler.net
all games recorded by the West Virginia
Lottery please play responsibly in
partnership with Hollywood Casino and
Charlestown Races and can I help is
available for problem gambling call
888-789-77 or visit
ccpg.org 21 and over in most eligible
States but state but age varies by
jurisdiction C drivekings.com Sportsbook
for details and say specific responsible
gambling resources bonus bets expire
seven days after issuance eligibility
and deposit restrictions apply terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com
fighter and the last number was
888-789-777
macadamia nuts dude that's what we
should be talking about everybody from
Tim Ferriss and Joe Rogan and Rick Rubin
talk about it they are possibly the best
nut for fat loss they are the best for
satiety what does that mean when you're
hungry you eat a cup of macadamia nuts
nothing is better than curbing your
Apple they're also the best tables
they're the best tasting they're great
snacks they've been around the studio
all the time you get the chocolate
covered there you have the dip white
chocolate there we got the raspberry
dipped chocolate the bars are great a
lot of people anti-aging
get involved
it's linked to collagen
producing infamous Nation all these
things are key parts of laundry it's not
just for the rich anymore man our
friends at House of macadamias are
making it accessible to everybody
because it's a farmer owned they
guarantee the best quality and prices
all right no added sugars no artificial
ingredients they got you covered you're
talking about just nuts and delicious
flavors their hands sort of nuts with
Savory all natural flavors or even
dipped in chocolate give them a deal
Brian quit talking about nuts I'll give
you a deal how about how about you guys
get a free box of sea salted macadamia
nuts and how about I get that sea salt
from the Bay of Namibia do you guys know
where that is of course not it's in
Africa the Dark Continent and that
namibian sea salt I haven't tried it
personally but it I should go through
the chocolate covered it's so
deliciously salty but they put just
enough it's from the sea they're
fantastic yep go to House of
macadamus.comtfak you get 20 off your
entire order with a CO
with those free nuts
namibian sea salt say it right Namibia
namibian
dude cowboy and this Saturday 7 PM
Pacific we got Brian the kid calendar
the Schmo and Pauly Shore I'm sorry it's
been a fun crew it's gonna be great now
who's fighting Charles Oliveira we're
just going to get into that yeah not the
best card I was going to say this is
going to cost you 80 to watch not the
best card there's actually probably one
fight you want to see on there that's
Darius and Charles Oliver that's I'm
outside that I'm very excited about that
that's what I said that fight's so good
take my money but the rest of card ye
garbage yeah it's a big big thing for
this is a big one for Charles Oliveira
in a way it's big for Darius Darius wins
this he no doubt he's a title shot well
so so what I mean is that if Charles
Oliveira loses this it becomes a strange
place for him he's still great not
really we'll only have out there is like
okay so he lost a mock champ okay Mark
Johnson beat most guys outside that he
won 11 in a row before that lost a mock
he's beat everybody what I mean is that
I always notice that with fighting in
the UFC the losing can sometimes it's
very hard to come back from that not him
though yeah because he's been there
before he he was just like he was like a
500 fighter yeah and they went on this
insane run so he can I'm not worried
about him mentally with the loss yeah it
with the level he's at it's like a
matchups dude she's a bad matchup what
makes Dario's so funny he's getting
everything and he has a granite chin
he's hard to take out
world champion Jiu Jitsu great jujitsu
guy great kickboxer these are heavy
hands I don't have a great chin no no
pretty traditional but just it has a
granite chinning can [__] he you know
he has he has got on his side well I was
about to say he's got he's got here's
the thing I got a couple things to say
about him first of all got his black
belt in five years that's not easy so
he's a quick study he gets better and
better he improves and proves and proves
secondly he um he's got the holy ghost
power on his side he was always winning
from Blue Bell to purple to brown belt
look at that world champions and all I
mean so he's just a winner man
is that it yeah well but it's it's an X
Factor that he registry in the Wikipedia
give me your thoughts though right well
it's an X Factor yeah like he's never
not won so he understands how to win
like no you this is Brian dude you know
Darius Mary has one daughter dude you
know he was born in 1991 no no and uh
he's got an X Factor his faith is
Christian nope he's got an X Factor his
ability you know his X factors he's won
10 in a row Brian well this would be
nine I'm sorry this but he was winning
before that too as a blue belt he was
winning as well you're talking about Jiu
Jitsu yeah but I'm just saying that
mindset is that mindset but be everybody
in the UFC has that is that that's true
everyone that gets to UC is Winners dude
yeah look at how many he's won so that's
not that that's not the that wouldn't be
I mean give me why you think Oliver
maybe that would be an X Factor though
say he's one from jujitu because then
every wrestler would just go into
dominates true yeah that's true so give
me why you think he would uh lose to
Oliveira I don't think he's gonna lose I
think he beats him and also a lot of
times Oliver he oh he starts off slow he
usually gets hit can't do that when he
gets hit his Jujitsu is so good guys are
usually they let him recover like a
Chandler or someone because they're
scared to grow the ground with him
Darius can Rock him go the ground Darius
is not scared of Jiu Jitsu they're both
pretty comparable he can nullify his
Jujitsu I think Darius rocks him and
then submits him if he doesn't knock him
out wow it's just a bad man
striking is damn good but his hands are
heavy too to be fair uh Oliver nice
heavy is Darius but he has more finishes
but
the the they both get hit that's why
it's gonna be it's a great fight again
the UFC whatever it's a bad card I would
pay 80 if this was the only fight on the
card like the others or whatever I'll
watch it I got problems I'll watch
anything you know yeah all of our beats
Darius battle shot
you don't think there's a shoddy Pizza
no I said no I said he'll get a title
shot I was gonna say whatever
sure so title shot so that so it's a
rematch with our boy uh Mark Joe
um she Mexican that's right and vaccines
are hot right now Mexicans are so hot
right now
they're just they have all the belts in
the UC this will be what the four
Champion Max sick yeah isn't it crazy
yeah one intern
not surprising now she's a dog but I
think she's gonna win I have a good
yeah I think she's over that weight cut
she has kids now there's been rumors
that even going into that camp
um you know that she wasn't against Pena
she wasn't really all you know both feet
in so that something's going on here
she's 35 that weight Cut's a [__] she'd
much prefer to fight at 45.
you know
so we'll see I can guarantee this the
fight command will be more entertaining
than that card guaranteed yeah
but I like those fights I love watching
a man in Nunez fight and I love watching
Charles Oliver troll it I mean that's a
great fight this Darius this is a huge
so that wasn't supposed to be on even on
the card they weren't supposed to get
that fight Bruce was fight earlier and
uh Charles Oliver pulled out so he got
postponed to this so this card was gonna
be even more junk that's the only that's
the only thing is it junk because we
don't know them or is it junk people no
it's junk again this is a knock on the
fire it's junk because the the matchups
this isn't this isn't a fighter that's
made to be exciting I mean I don't know
anybody there
it's tough the next best fight on the
car is probably that Dan ige and Nate uh
landwear that's a great fight well wait
is that otherwise okay
like to kick off the main event of the
main card that's probably a decision you
know the way they fight uh it's just not
great it's all good happens it's all
good baby all good my nuggets lost dude
I'll tell you what I thought my brother
cured his anger management issues
and he was like no I can't watch I'll I
can't sleep at night you know because if
I watch the Nuggets so the game was on
right he's that big of a fan yeah he's
that big a fan I was like no you'd be
fine man put the game on and we're in
the Green Room
dude they they were up like eight and I
was like you're fine he's so negative
about it he said no they're just not
playing well they're not doing well blah
blah I'm like all right you're so
negative they end up losing
but I don't get to see that because when
they went down eight in the fourth
quarter he slammed his phone to the
ground in The Green Room oh he had
promised it they can their NBA team they
can come back on run he's like I don't
give a [__]
this morning man just just because he's
that much of a nuggets fan yeah I don't
take that [__] personally I don't either
I'm just in a city but I was also like
just from Aurora it's not a big deal
yeah but we grew up next to number one
anything ever now they finally can
they're kind of one to one but they can
make so many changes and win the game
like I think they're winning five it's
all good I guarantee they win they were
lazy this game they thought they had
they they rolled over into the heat it's
to be expected I guess the next and also
I told Jay I said it's good from this
little wake-up call like they've been
coat they they coasted through the
Lakers they coasted and they destroyed
the Lakers didn't lose a game they
coasted through Phoenix like it's been
an easy run for him so finally they get
a little pushback they're a little too
comfortable get a little too cocky can't
get too but it's again it's not joking
she's best player in the NBA by far the
MVP but the rest of the players didn't
they just didn't show up yeah I was
watching that guy I don't know anything
about basketball and I don't watch but I
was because people have been talking
about I was watching him and watching
how
um he can the way he passed IQ yeah best
pastor in the NBA unbelievable for a big
guy insane and the way he hits from
wherever he's huge too he's just six
eleven yeah
but again he's not I mean if you like
fundamentals and good basketball he's
the best player to watch but as far as
like exciting no he's not that flashy
his pass is about to flash his thing
he's not quick he's not the quickest guy
stick around draft pick like there's
nothing flashy about him that's why the
NBA knows he's not on the face of ESPN
because you know it's just a joke he
does his interviews doesn't give a [__]
yeah didn't care about any of that I
think only wants to win I think in
Montenegro uh where he is like some of
the serbs are from I think they're the
tallest people in Europe people say
Holland but I think they're actually I
think they're the tallest
and there's a small section of
Montenegro I think cool man I think
that's where he's from they're Giants
you know what they call them El giantes
they call them Land of the Giants they
do no I do
modern things are just behind the Dutch
second tallest country in the world
so the average height of a male in
Montenegro is six foot wow
where's five nine in the United States
my son for a girl's tall too it's funny
how how rare 6'4 still is
yeah I can [__] order RVs
[__] Shaquille O'Neal dude yep it's
embarrassing my dad always had that I
can't shop size 14 shoe but also his
feet were wide yeah he's my desk but
like Frankenstein yeah it's a nightmare
if you're like just a bigger male like
there's certain especially like high-end
fashion forget about it I can't go in
there and buy stuff off the shelf
not a chance yeah no way it's a real
curse you can't right you can't buy
suits what's yours what what suit do you
what size suit 140 regular I don't know
58 I think 54.
when might when when the this is how
ridiculous my friends are when I was in
my late 30s maybe 40 later when Hulk
came out the first Hulk came out Lou
Ferrigno no with Eric Bana
oh remember yeah you talking about a
movie like yeah but it was a live-action
movie you see when that came out please
there my friend would call me in college
my friend would call me was and he'd go
like this he'd go 2003.
2003 okay
my friend would [__] call me I I was
37 or whatever my friend would call me
and go uh
hey dude
uh I'm thinking his he takes a size
400 in suit
I go what the Hulk you go what do you
think his when he's at his biggest what
do you think his suit size is like if he
had to be fitted for a Blazer your
friend's immature I'm like I I don't
know he goes I'm I'm saying he's over
200. so you're a 40 regular I'm giving
him I'm giving him 200. and then then I
would then he'd go all right let me hang
up the phone because he was training
yeah then he goes he goes
I got news for you dude what do you
think he benches and I go I don't know
and he goes well he picked the tank up
and he was swinging it so I'm thinking
he's binging Jesus Christ fifty thousand
pounds
I I can't have these conversations your
friend's stupid huh yeah
that when he's his biggest the original
I think you're talking about Lou
Ferrigno the original Hulk and he was so
jacked they just spray painted him green
that's right instead of computer but
that is a big hulky hump
a Hulk's dope
yeah
they've never really made a good Hulk
movie though they just never hit it out
the part I agree they need to redo that
that's all Hollywood does anyway because
the idea is kind of stupid also I could
never go over the pants issue he's
wearing pants
and he's huge he'd be naked
y'all don't know man
I don't like yeah I don't like this
conversation I don't like superhero
movies
who's your favorite superhero I do want
to see that new spider verse I heard
it's like the best comic book movie ever
I'm sure did you see the original the
well when I say the original original
Spider verse I saw John Wick four well
that's not super everybody's talking
about how great it is I'm just too old
and all that stuff I don't if all this
is action it's not well it is dude it's
not for me but why is everybody raving
about I crushed into the theaters but
just like just shooting and karate and
it's like oh God no I don't like you
neither I don't I've never seen anything
a thousand times guys
no not for me but did you see that
Spider-Man is supposed to be really good
I
uh it's crushing it and um
oh what's his name clay Travis who we
love he we kind of usually we have the
same political opinion some I don't
agree with everything he says but he
said it was good so I'm like I can't be
too woke
because I know there's a pregnant
Spider-Man wants to show the power of
pregnant women can still be badass why
yeah there's a pregnant Spider-Man it's
all these multiverses also Multiverse
Rick and Morty's been doing it for I
don't know six years now you know so
he's jumping over all these Multiverse
so I don't know
yeah I mean I don't know man I want to
see it apparently it's long though my
son's friend had a birthday party there
and my girl calls me on Saturday and
she's like it's chaos she's like it's
like a three-hour movie these kids are
not into it I'm like cats three hours
yeah I got a kiss I gotta kick out of it
220. yeah it's crushing in the theaters
but um and Little Mermaid did so well in
the United States and then when I went
to China people were like we don't like
blacks what yeah nobody went to see it
because they were like oh wait wait
Little Mermaid's always been white and
we just feel like it's you know it's
like oh God it's like hey China you know
mermaids aren't real though yeah I mean
that that is really interesting because
China basically their minister of
cultural Affairs said something like
it's been a beloved person and you guys
are trying to push your your agenda down
our throats and you know I mean they're
a little right yeah but also it's fine
that the little mermaid is
has darker pigmentation then I mean it's
a little awoke when it's the the Five
Sisters and one's Asian one's white
one's from Africa one's Indian the dad's
Spanish it's like all right hey guys
we're representing a lot here yeah
they're also fish yeah right
that is a good conversation though right
because some movies were written or the
books are written for like a certain
character but they try to be woke and
they change that character to a
different ethnicity yeah I don't think
that's I don't think they should do that
I think just write an original script
for that whatever ethnicity you want
yeah whatever yeah but don't just don't
make old ones the best actor and best
character for the part the best actor
for the part whatever the best the best
to be fair that girl is damn good in it
she can sing she's a dime piece like she
has eyes like a fish yeah fries are so
wide apart right can I see the real
person though her eyes are so far apart
like a fish well don't say that please
why so
she's so talented she's sang during the
American Idol my God she can sing really
she's a dime piece too I don't know how
old she is so let's make sure we're good
so 23 we're in the clear eyes are far
apart though right I mean they are let's
just pray again
to be clear it's all good
I'm just saying her eyes I'm not saying
it's a bad thing I'm saying it it gives
it a fish look
is that is that negative I am I am you
tell me the people that are in cast were
like dude did you spot out I am not and
she can sing she can swim checks all
boxes I don't know Brennan uh very
pretty and let me see some more pictures
there you go yeah yeah she's I mean I
will say if you were dating her you
might be like hello you know I had a
girlfriend who had very far apart
beautiful beautiful can you tell me if
you're dating her and she left the room
on like here eyes are far apart look at
her I would not I'd say she's gorgeous
time oh dude she's so good gorgeous no
obviously that's I'm talented but I will
admit her eyes are not close together
you never say you never say her eyes are
too close together compared to me her
eyes are further you would never say
that your eyes are look at her body
you're you would never say your eyes are
very close no don't get it twisted she's
a bona fide she's Court hen oh she's
like old school Hollywood Scarlet yeah
she's gorgeous Jesus
not a bad thing yeah gorgeous
I'm saying compared to me it has a
further that's a good thing there you go
so your eyes are standardly spaced and
her eyes might be a little bit Yeah Yeah
she's so talented though
she's a cutie pie
good for her movie's all right but even
even the cartoon it's all right he's a
little too long
what's wrong the cartoon little too long
under the sea
I'm not too it didn't do it yeah I do
want to see spiders but I can't go to my
son's scene did you see Netflix the sex
life absolutely not man
well I Got Hijacked into that is that
the lesbian one no no it's actually
interesting go to sex life go to Adam
Demo's full frontal go to Adam demos
Adam can you help me spell Adam right
there Adam is it a reality show or it's
a scripted no it's a scripted full
frontal yeah I got a full frontal I'm
not gonna say anything
let's go ahead and get some images on
that
is that it
yeah but that's all they show is wee-wee
yeah but can we see it I mean I'm sure
we can but there goes my computer again
there's a big one editing fail
yes oh is it photoshopped is it like I
mean now it is I've never seen a dick
this big
so it's down to here yeah oh no that's
not real
but I'm sure when he's negotiating it's
like hey you got a new scene he's like
well so it's so real looking dude but it
turned out it was a prosthetic but it's
what they can do with prosthetics what
they can do with prosthetics I literally
was like this I saw it and I went
because so the guy his this his wife is
crazy about him can't kick him so he
goes and takes a shower with the guy
he's stalking him and he sees his dick
and he just goes like this
like it's well you remember Dirk Diggler
and Boogie Nights they showed his yeah
because that is a prosthetic that's
[__] yeah that's a good size this
looks real well that look real too yeah
but this is Dirk Douglas was too skinny
this thing is I mean it's it's girthy
it's like we have to get a picture of it
I don't know if we can of course we
can't show it obviously he's trending on
Tick Tock it's hilarious but they do so
don't you get banned on Tick Tock if you
show weiner they do such a good job with
this [__] man I don't know maybe
I mean out of all the out of all the
out of all this the computer generated
Graphics this is what you're impressed
with
the still weiner yeah they're not Hulk
it's all that matters there you go there
you go
but that does that doesn't look real
it didn't if you see the show and I was
like and everybody was like what the
[__] I went immediately to my phone like
let me see if that's real but everybody
thought that was real because they do
such a good job with it they should have
gave him some more ass yeah now now this
guy this guy yes he doesn't have an ass
yes good actor flat ass yeah yeah
that's a long wiener man the movie the
the show itself it also the reason you
know it's fake it's I mean I guess if he
just got done you know busting then it's
gonna be a little filled like that but
no one's Weiner's that hard just
chilling I've seen or that long I've
seen dicks that like that on on uh on
not white guys and but on Puerto Rican
guy at the YMCA one time in Hoboken hey
hey see once you step out of the white
race then yeah for sure we're talking
about white that white guy with a flat
ass that he ain't packing that heat no
no and flaccid like that come on dude
now go to Dirk diggler's who's better
because that one looks a little fake to
me B that one yeah if you see it in in
the show it's I just saw it
so real
Dirks and zundies was popping but
there's it's a very it's the last scene
in the movie
that's a great show movie
yeah it wasn't good I remember it oh
that movie's great dude I think the
movie's great the movie's great I mean
we got this no no no yeah well that's
that's uh this looks like a real no
nevermind but that's that's uh Thor
we're looking for Mark Wahlberg in
Boogie Nights
oh is that that's it right there where
him in the white suit yeah here yeah see
how it's skinny oh well that looks so
fake yeah and skinny and you know what
but it I'd say that looks more real than
uh the other one no it doesn't I'm
telling you I I you have to see the show
I mean it's it's real what they do with
prosthetics now is you would never be
able to tell you be like what the [__]
well for sure they can pull off [__]
spider-verse workout things
alrighty I was checked out our wieners
for the day yeah which we always it
always comes down to dicks it's amazing
you brought it up dude well I just
referenced Boogie Nights you're right
there's not a lot of moves that show
this I want to watch that movie again
that's a great movie oh it's on all the
time I always watch it it's such a good
movie I only like to begin with having
fun at the party at Burt Reynolds and at
the end it gets sad you see how it ends
for everybody well that's kind of you
know yeah yeah if you're gonna go down
that
when you do it like porn stuff the kind
of [__] I have like the kind my search
engine is uh hot black guys huge black
cops I mean I the silly government sees
all that stuff I don't the amount of
stuff I send to friends and
to even my wife who my wife you know
dated
black guys in college and I will send
her pictures of some total stud say is
this your style and I'm like and I just
write slot underneath it that's nice I
know she's like what's wrong with you
I'm like we should honor uh it's pride
month and we have a video to honor pride
month I sent it to Chin yeah we should
watch it only problem with that is uh we
got flagged because that's part of the
fox thing or whatever yeah but it's on
your Instagram right yeah so just check
out Brendan's Instagram haters haters
man haters what are you doing for pride
month me cousin [__] guys [__]
strangers that's how I show my respect
get in them cheese yeah
Pride it's a month it's a whole month
whole month
it's a lot of time it's a long month
yeah
show some respect piece of [__]
it's all good
what do you got Jen
alrighty let's see
oh wait so I don't know if you know that
we got besides wieners Jen this dude I'm
just curious if you knew who this guy is
his name is Jackie Chen
he's an Asian dude
Pam or pan homeboy's thick he's six
three ten yo [__] six six 310 pounds I
would have played tackle and he's uh he
got signed by the Minnesota Vikings damn
but he's never played before I take it
no he was like uh or in the NFL no but
like uh whatever is before you played in
college yeah where at right here
Style Port Jefferson High School hold on
I don't know
um oh wait all academic honor roll name
neo10 for steam All Conference
yeah I don't know any of that stuff
division two so maybe he's straight from
high school then no sounds like he's
played in division two
okay yeah I don't know
yeah that's the biggest Asian dude
that's a giant Asian man you sure Mom
wasn't Samoan or something because I'm
I'm like I gotta see what his background
is he looks super Chinese stud being
that big though yeah they're gonna try
and figure it out
so he signed as a free agent
homeboy's a big man
yeah he's massive
is your favorite player now Jen I barely
learned about this guy he hasn't made it
yet though he's just bring him to Camp
like you to Brock Lesnar or me
what do you think about this latest fall
from uh Biden what's weird is if you're
left or right can we acknowledge like
you can't have the leader of the Free
World Fallen all over the place what's
weird to me is people if you're left and
you can defend your guy I'll see people
smart people like I fall all the time I
don't see the problem here and also did
you see his shoes
do you see it you know they have shoes
that he locks into all right so he can't
Sway and fall down so they zoomed in on
shoes and you don't that Michael Jackson
wear the same shoes you know you would
lean really forward and back he had
things on the on the stage where he'd
lock in so he could lean far and back
but has the same thing so he can't fall
back and forwards well he tripped over a
sandbag there that's what he says you
know it's a fall at that age can be very
serious but it keeps falling
yep that's besides the point Brian the
point is the leader of the Free World
keeps [__] falling and we're all just
like I fall time too I don't see the
problem here it's like well the problem
is it just makes us look weak yeah the
problem is we've not had a president
falsely goddamn time he's very he's
compromised he's frail and he's he could
be cognitively challenged so at least we
have well hold on correct your statement
could be well we we have President
Harris thank God thank God
thank God because she's so good thank
God that the and so likable Democratic
operatives can't wait for him to be
pronounced you know he's going to run in
2024. he would be I think 86 if but at
the end of the term there's no way 86
there's no way no he'll he could live in
that long system he's right now
apparently he's working five hour days
wow we need more we need more so
um you can't have the two of us working
tomorrow I can't have the two of us
working more hours in a day than the
president they're putting him
um
pop of
they're putting Kamala Harris in high
profile positions but she just has the
lowest rating a lot of people hate her
she's just so fake yeah I feel so bad
for my computer yeah so this I mean
since we're talking about falling stuff
so Michael J fox was at a Expo Back to
the Future Expo and in Philadelphia see
this this makes me sad because Michael J
fox he's not the leader of the free one
like this this makes sense he has
Parkinson's it sucks yeah but um
[Applause]
but his attitude is dude is so good
so he's like
hold on there he goes and luckily he
fell on the couch so it's not bad but
he's just playing around with it now
[Applause]
[Music]
anyhow yeah it's a bummer it is a bummer
for sure it's so hard to be uh
it's so hard man and Parkinson's do we
know that like this so Parkinson
degenerative disease right so you're
disease because he went back in time
no but I think that uh gonna go back in
time when you think about how lucky you
are like um Jamie Foxx apparently is
paralyzed and blind what no yes
right now apparently I heard it was a
stroke apparently [__] like I said
when I said like I said it was from a
shot that he remember when I said it was
a stroke a long time ago yeah remember
that yeah because I knew I had but now
but are you breaking news saying that
he's paralyzed and blind so it's not me
saying that that's what Tyson said
that's what some other people no Tyson
said he had a stroke because of the shot
I hope he wasn't
so it's by that Brian be on Tick Tock
and [__] spreading rumors that's where
he got it from you piece of [__] yeah
I think this I I hope I'm wrong I really
that was him and Ray but I haven't been
wrong so far
for a reason yeah I agree I haven't been
wrong
but there's no Hodge twins that's what's
coming from yeah it's not just them here
go back up please
go back up up higher yeah here uh claim
you have paralyzed and blind due to a
blood clot
um there's a lot of people talking about
it and there's a reason you haven't seen
them yeah I agree
and uh hold on can you imagine what that
would do for those shots if this was
true that he got they can't even prove
that though that'll never come out well
no it'll never well but that's gonna be
the narrative guarantee it stink with
the hit it's going to take for that
whether you believe in them or not like
that's a big deal so why would he go
over here sad to see how the media runs
wild my dad has been out of the hospital
for weeks recuperating so he's playing
pickleball in fact he was playing
pickleball yesterday thanks for
everyone's present support thank God uh
uh it was all baloney that they were
reporting he's playing pickleball he's
responding he no he's not it's always
thank God I really pray that's true so
he's playing pickleball yesterday who
knows what to believe that's what gets
nicey right well you know yeah
yeah
I think there's probably some stuff
going on and and he needs to recoup he's
probably in rehab right that's what you
do with a stroke victim and so hopefully
he doesn't want people seeing that he
can't yes
I love that guy so so during the
exchange doctors who clarified that Benz
uh said Fox had a blood clot in the
brain
that was incorrect but I meant he had a
stroke and his kids would because of a
blood clot Jesus Christ
and that goes on to say about you know
yeah that stuff
that would be insane if that's true
I mean blind and paralyzed
I don't know man but then was his
daughter saying he's playing pickleball
I think so yeah current Fox yeah
who knows now this is smart so people
petting yes how many times people have
we seen try to cut up it always happens
all the time but but but buffaloes
aren't even like a friendly Disney
animal that's how rough they are oh yeah
so what gives you the impression that
these things would be cool with yourself
because you're a [__] idiot and when
I lit listen to the background it sounds
like they're foreign so maybe they don't
read the signs properly I don't know but
anyways it's almost always Asian or
someone who's there's not really I mean
science but you need to know this yeah
let me see him get trucked by this
bicycle it's not that bad so here we go
but I mean it could have gotten way
worse well they have no idea but the
fact that people are still doing it is
so insane to me
I'm with this guy natural selection like
if you're that stupid guilt to a giant
buffalo and get a selfie
place to be games when stupid prizes and
the park can only do so much like hey
man don't take selfies with 2 000 pound
bison right we've told you three times
now
okay um so what do you guys think of
lamelo's I saw it it looks like it was
hurt it looks like some from The Little
Mermaid
they said something you would find Under
the Sea very coral-esque that is
you know what that is you know what that
is stupid yeah it does look like it's a
little mermaid yeah and then this is
like the another one yeah so what does
that thing cost oh my God I tried to
look at the price I couldn't find the
price but it's gonna be seven figures
yeah it's gonna be expensive
call that a bad investment yeah
um here is Kanye West and his girl
at a church Castle
he is so strange that's their new
outfits for a church you know that's
police in german yes he's wearing um oh
he's wearing he's
oh can they can we acknowledge how down
is his girl like he's like hold on [__]
before we get in there let me put this
over your face she's like you think you
look good he's like it's easy season
seven baby she's wearing a body stocking
yeah but the things come in her like
keep I'm down to where the weird anus
thing but do I have to cover my face he
doesn't have a great flattering lower
body uh I mean no no his body's terrible
you're the same meaning
yeah I I just don't get well if you're a
girl this girl is gorgeous she's like do
I have to cover my face though the
answer is kind of my money maker he goes
can we cover your face but leave the
tits out yeah
she's gorgeous I'm like I'm not covering
my face dude but again
found a loyal one dude she's down oh
there you go that's cool oh that was
that was his fashion show he literally
just put tape over her [__] like that
really yeah
that was the fashion show
all right fascinating character let's
keep happening yeah
so Georgie has this one a fan sent this
in this was a nambibia boxing match
that's where the Salted macadamias come
from yeah they got some sweat off these
two oh no oh my God
got knocked out right boom I don't like
seeing that
it does suck but yeah
shout out now can't play boxing right
Brennan
my friend no get out of here oh and also
Georgie
what happened
so these students pranked their teacher
by all camping out in her living room
for when she woke up they broke in yeah
I don't get the pranks these days I'm
just an older man you took her well
good morning little bunny
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
there you go
through the paint that'd be weird but I
told him you guys broke in when I was
sleeping like yeah
that could have went really sideways
that teacher was more gangster 100.
I mean I I uh my senior year yes senior
year or maybe was eighth to ninth grade
we uh tea beat the school
I've never sleeping we put a car on top
of a roof
how'd you do that we didn't I know you
did see I knew the LIE already I was
like how would you do that
that's some rich kid [__] though my
friend yeah okay
what's this someone being a dumbass on a
plane
do you know much about this Georgie
flight delays intoxicated Pastor offense
everybody on the plane
I'll just play a little bit of it then
[Music]
please please
come on
um
[Music]
did you see someone open up the Escape
exit oh yeah yeah that was crazy now in
the movies
in the movies
yeah that's not good
I wasn't the rumor that it's impossible
to open it is they were 700 feet there
were 700 feet off the ground oh but if
you had a 10 000 no pressurized there's
no way yeah yeah because there was that
defensive end who got had a manic
episode they couldn't get a giant guy he
was trying to open the plane door but
you can't right no thank you but if
you're less than thousand feet you can
no you can usually they must have
depressurized or something yeah okay
yeah that's it
pretty sure that oh wait how about this
this is a body transformation he kind of
reminds me of Bilal a little bit
but
that's how he starts great tell you some
tits damn
so we're just looking at a he had to
have surgery though right sure I'm sure
kg yeah surgery for those titties so far
no right so it keeps going and going
like he actually developed ABS this is
over how many years I don't know how
many years
he still has a sag yeah I think he
probably had dude after all the yeah he
definitely had a commercial he
definitely had some stuff removed not
yet though not yet yeah so we'll see at
the end of it but he gets jacked that's
insane
that is so impressive
I don't know if I don't know if he's had
anything done I don't think so because
he would have got rid of that skin look
at his Trapster elastic back pretty
naturally well that is a damn good for
him man that really is amazing
wow that's freaking dope man he was so
thick yeah timepiece
impressive that's you Georgie that's
right buddy
that's you give it time you were even
bigger than him though George that's
what's crazy boy he looks fantastic yeah
dude if he removes that
I am popping yeah
Poppin bro popping Daddy
it looks fantastic I wonder what he did
change disease and drastically oh I mean
that's to say exercise appreciate the
love so this is the guy and took time
like it looks like it took a long time
as it should that looks crazy it took
all the time so that was a lot of picks
yeah
it doesn't look like he said the
surgeries or anything just tighten it
tighten the skin up
it's kind of hard to tell though yeah it
is but he looks like a motivational
speaker which he should be oh yeah I
agree yeah
wow what's that video he goes I don't
want loose skin you see it
yeah
it depends on so many factors like your
genetics
how old you really are how much muscle
you've actually built
regardless and it is not that big of a
deal trust me don't use that as an
excuse me
too fast
what do you say about put to sleep
he's worried about getting put to sleep
and then wake up in heaven and die
because anesthesia you know so bad for
you Fair Point yeah the skin though he's
bodied up yeah absolutely I mean it's
jacked like what the [__] yeah that's
pretty crazy
yeah he had some double D's earlier that
was some tits those are real tips
uh oh yeah the weekend
yeah I found a photo of a couple summers
ago me at uh the lake beach Lake
Michigan beach before you this is gonna
be insane when you guys see this picture
we've seen pictures of Georgie before
bigger than this guy oh my goodness
I have a open button-up shirt on and a
towel over me what were you what were
you um eating yeah I named something
name something everything
what would you say just what was your
breakfast for example I my issue was
binge eating I would like not late at
night yeah I would not eat most today
and then eat an excessive amount at
night time alone what's the excessive
amount for we're talking about two large
cheese pizzas what are we talking about
like it would be like a full pizza or
like two triple cheeseburgers something
that's not terrible but but all packed
on at night time when you go to bed so
the it's packed it sits on you soda a
lot of soda during the day sugary
beverages empty sugar gotta do it yeah
booze uh a little bit
I stopped uh drinking all together when
I started the diet any drugs a little
back in the day oh you have some fun you
don't see a lot of drug users
oh George is insanely inspirational you
could do an inspirational thing like
that dude man oh yeah that'd be done
public speaking up a little bit
Trump calls us everybody for being
lowest energy I've ever seen
low energy today doesn't feel like
really okay good I feel low energy I
feel like I'm not offering anything
I feel like I'm blank right now I'm like
do you even learn the pain on the trans
stuff I want to kind of sparked a little
fire under you yeah kept saying that
girl's like blowing everybody away but
that was annoying bring up the challenge
I don't want to bring up bring up see
what college Michael uh I got the issues
speaking of D1 I can Sprint in these
[__] man you could get beat by a
trans woman though
is that a chin that's it all right I'll
be with Brian Tuesday night where are we
going to be be Venice uh Venice West in
Venice to California
Yeah Eddie Bravo Sam Tripoli Jeff died
she'll be a fun time maybe a special
guest
um next I'll be doing sets around La we
have a fight command this Saturday 7 P.M
live on thick boy YouTube for UFC 289
the Schmo Talon and a long break Polly
Shore taking a long break yes I'm
chilling this something with the kiddos
nice so uh next one's the Ice House in
Pasadena July 28th spoken September
skank Fest 29th of September Niagara
Falls November all right kids love you
we're out yeah
gotta piss hard I got a piss